You have interrupted a citywide investigation
You stole evidence from my crime scene
And you got my one lead killed.
I Was trying to help him. [But you didn't]
Jessica Jones stop talking. [Who the hell are you?] my name is Matthew murdock. I'm your attorney.
How does being harlem's hero allow you to live an actual life? Right now, I just wanna help people
I think there's someone you need to meet. Hey, what are you doing in there? [Help]
Who are you? Who are you?
How come you can't be hurt? What's the deal with that fist?
I'm the immortal iron fist. You what?  You're on the same side.
the Devil of Hell's kitchen
The smartass detective, [We got a problem?]
The Righteous ex Cohen [My bad] and the kid with the glowing fist
the war for New York is here
So get your shit together
The more connections you have
The easier it will be to break you. You look like an idiot
your scarf
We make quite a team. [No]. What you talking about? The bullet proof, a blind Ninja? Whatever it is you are?
Classy.
you